all right so uh when you do any
technique actually you do have like a a
you always have a Yin yield in your keyh
horn
okay but what happens is that our Yin
yield is
external so he is pushing per
prescription and then I just kind of get
out of way and he kind of Falls
forward right so he's pushing for
prescription and I get out of the way he
falls forward and then I go okay the
downside of that is I'm not actually in
control of
him now the inertia may be in control of
him but that is not the point of your
Keon waza okay it's not someone's coming
at you get out of the way like a bull
fighter gets out of the way okay
uh and it's hard to see that when I'm
doing my stuff that I'm I'm in his
Center he he can feel it you see he can
feel it he could feel it but you can't
see it okay and so it's very easy that
when I come back here it looks like
that but I'll show you I'll show you
what to look for okay so for example if
I just get out of the
way got it
on this if I were to
stop he would be able to push it push it
in if I'm just getting out of the way or
if he's faster than me you got it and I
get out of the way you see it got stuck
you guys see that okay but when I am
moving his Center I you could stop at
any point push doesn't change it it
makes him move doesn't change it we'll
go over here push makes him move do you
see so when I go around it's not that
I'm getting out of the way I have his
Center and his whole Center is making a
big
circle okay so
now I gave you one metric he can't push
on it it would be it's pushing him back
okay but the next one I want you to do
is now watch is Center okay so don't
don't get caught in the flash of the
hand work don't get caught in the flash
of the throat you're you're looking
here okay and when I just get out of the
way you see nothing really happens to
that Center except for the fact that it
fell forward got it but when I do this
movement and I have this Center you see
how Center is
moving
so here nothing happens till you get in
there but here in the
center
that that whole thing moved in that
Circle okay so your yield moves are not
just external bull fighter Cape moved
the cape out of the way the bull fell in
and then knocked him over you have a
center you're moving into that pattern
moving into that pnom you see
boom okay let's see if we can bring some
internal to the external Yin yield okay
let's try
to okay so uh as you're trying to do
your Kona remember the point of the
Kona is ultimately communion with God
which means you are going to reduce the
activity of the ego tripartite mind
allowing the god mind to arise okay so
you have to get yourself in Lial
States and to the the tried and truee
way of getting into Lial States is to
solving for
[Music]
dichotomy and basically generating
paradoxes philosophically speaking so
for
example it makes sense to the
dichotomist mind that he's
pushing and you do the bull fighter get
out of the way that makes sense
okay it does not make sense that I would
have uh his Center and that at these
weird
angles that he's still pushing he can't
do anything we we would be here all day
okay it also makes sense to the
dichotomous mind to be pushing him do
you see to push him over that I get a
skeletal alignment and then I just kind
of push him
over
likewise if I'm asking you to move his
Center it makes sense on the in hand to
pull so you're like okay I'll pull him
in with that Yin hand and that makes
sense to you but it's really this hand
that's
important okay so here this was in your
mind either you're getting out of the
way hand or your pushing hand do you see
that but it's going to do both so it
it's going to move his center around
this
way keep your
grip you
see you get that it's not that I'm going
here it's moving
him that way it's
both projecting and
adhering okay so that so don't get so
stuck cuz you're over here and you're
like I am moving it but this hand's just
waiting do you see and he's not doing
anything till it makes sense to now push
him over
okay likewise all although this hand is
moving him again the same thing here's a
weird angle push on it push on it that
way we're we're not going anywhere we're
not going
anywhere do you get it it's not getting
out of the way and pulling
him such that if he pulls it back
doesn't do anything it's stuck he pushes
it doesn't do anything do you see that
okay so pay attention you're not not
getting out of the way all this hand not
doing anything until it makes
dichotomous sense to push them
over the whole body
moves move his whole
body
okay try it
again all right
so regular Co C DOA as I said before we
did the first instructional period it's
like it kind of looks like it you know
what I mean like this kind of looks like
get out of the way it kind of looks it
kind of looks like it until you know
what to look for like the center or till
you know what to test for push push
we're not going anywhere pull we're not
going anywhere
okay then once you know what to look
for what to test for then it's
hard to lie to ourselves
okay but what I like to do is eventually
we'll do a version that you just can't
do the other way okay so that's what
we're going to do now you're probably
going to have to scoop back okay okay so
this one I'm I'm going to have his
Center I'm going to move his whole
Center send them right back the other
way
okay let's try it okay why this works as
a kind of test is I can't just get out
of the way CU he'll never turn okay so I
I have to I have to control his Center
you see and we go we'll go over here and
then I
turn there's there's a couple things to
notice to make sure that you're not half
assing it one is not t you
net it remains clo you
net and then
two is not going to go here you see that
he's kind of there you get it and then
now he's going this way
there you going totally turn
him
and
and uh a way you know you're in the
ballpark is the baduk is Will clamshell
on you can you I won't clamshell you but
can you show what clam shell
is yeah so he's he's like this
okay so you clam shell someone you could
for at least one rep go ah I'm doing it
okay but you should try to work with
your UK so I'll move him around you see
and then I can ease up and use the clam
shell just don't take him to here and
then think you're doing
[Music]
it if you pay attention he's going to
move all the way over to there and then
you can see the risk of the
clamshell okay let's try it
again okay so you have a technique where
you're uh do this technique in dto you
so you're you get his Center boom and
you'll have his shoulders locked okay I
I do that at first you see and then I
now I just want his Ted in and I'm going
to move his tonen
around so I'm not going like this cuz
this hand was dead you pay attention is
dead
hand down
here so you're going to pass through AAG
and then once you have the center you
turn
it this is why it's not teni
nugget this hand's
dead Bo
okay and we're not taking them to the
left or right R turning him all
here boom okay try it
again A lot of times you have this idea
of move your Center really amounts to
people turning their waist okay but we
don't ever turn the way so I do have
some Center realignment but it's from
the qua moving the qua opening and
closing I don't ever go like this this
is incorrect okay but people can get
very uh uh strong or powerful by just
having the biomechanics of moving from
the core of your body okay but then
people mistake that as correct
form so you see uh use your Center okay
so I I go in here you see my Center is
going up and then they'll turn their
waist you see and then they turn their
waist
back I haven't done that in a long time
man that felt weird that it's that's a
lot of strain on the other side to do it
okay um but here's the thing you're
trying to spiral rotate the
tanden but once you form the Tom Den
it's not because I actually physically
turn my waist that I would ever spir
rotate this the hands are actually
rotating the Yoni in my tanden okay so
my my hands
boom one
low one
high
okay and then over the top
drop so I can't do whatever I want with
my hands my hands have to spiral rotate
the hands have to spiral rotate they
can't make these circles like that you
see circles those are conducive to waist
movement okay and they always stress
your inner
deltoid to martially they're not going
to function unless they're this person's
lighter than your strength okay but
they'll never spiral rotate the lower T
then okay so as you're doing the
technique okay you're going to watch how
I'm doing an inward
spiral if you're not sure how to
recognize that
think okay so I go like
this that that's not it you see
that okay and I go like
this that's not
it
Bo so without him no no no
no no
okay so watch the Y hand in the
technique and it's going to
do
okay then the lower hand so it's a Yin
Yong world so as I do the inward spiral
on the Yang hand
right until it gets to that Yang phase
what do you think you have over here you
have the EM spiral you
see so as I go and you pay attention
this is actually the hour spiral do you
see it right
there if you're not sure what it looks
like you can see it in cooku
hole so as I go one I'm picking it up
with the outward spiral and then as I
reach its limal stage that's when it
converts to the inward spiral do you see
that
so I am from the bottom picking up so to
speak the lower toen and then over the
top spiraling
in
okay this hand will do
the
inverse so it's going to do the inverse
spiral and it's over the top of the
tanden until he starts to come back and
here is your outward spiral do you see
boom so now watch this hand it does the
inward W pop back
out okay so if I move out of the
way
oh this is where I am moving this thing
moving this thing moving this thing
okay hey